i want to get your opinion on some of
these names what we wanted to do because
obviously it's a financial show we talk
about
relationships tara's my friend that
moved to italy by the way she lives in
italy full-time here are a list of the
top 10 richest
porn stars these are never right but
let's see these are never
what i want to do right now is get your
initial reaction when you see their name
and you tell us what you think if these
if these are accurate or not so number
one on the list is the legendary jenna
jameson thoughts on jenna and her being
number one on this list jenna jameson's
going through a horrible health issue
right now she's lost her ability to walk
i don't know if you know this oh my gosh
she's been using a walker she's got some
mystery disease that they haven't
discovered yet so we should pass on her
and just send her love i believe
sending love to
speaking of just knowing names she was
the it girl in the 90s not even
questioned it was pamela anderson in in
on tv and it was janet jameson on the
porn i mean you are correct and stern
loved jenna she was on all the time she
was in stern's movie legend beautiful
uh well wishing her well straight up
number two is tara patrick
tara's done very well for herself but
she's had to deal with some controversy
she had a boyfriend who took a lot from
her that she ended up marrying she had a
back pimp type of a guy yeah but he had
it he didn't come off that way
he was in that show oz which i never
watched he was in the band biohazard but
it ended very poorly with him but i'll
tell you what she did that was brilliant
she was the first contract girl to want
to leave her contract it was digital
playground and they told her you can
leave but we own your name
and she spent you know court you know
what court costs she spent a [ __ ] ton of
money to make sure that that was never
gonna happen for her and so it could
never happen for another entertainer in
the industry and she
fought against the grain and i had to
give her so much she made all of us
smarter
by doing that and she empowered all of
us to understand our rights as
performers
um and so she's done well but she's
dealt with a lot of peaks and valleys
she just finished school um
she to be a lab tech to do compounds
with different types of pharmacies so
she did all that on her own her
daughter's brilliant speaks four
languages so tara is a gifted human
woman and beautiful and clearly just a
side note we'll move on but i i the the
the arm sleeve do you have any tattoos i
had one on the back of my neck and i had
it removed because i realized it was bad
you know women are just putting cats
everywhere when i first met tara she had
no tattoos at all and i went to a club
not too long ago to visit a friend and
and they had an old picture of tara in
the in a bikini on a poster and she had
no tattoos i'm like oh my gosh she looks
so different you know that's very
different living in italy is the tattoos
like that's something that people don't
really understand as much thoughts on
the on women who put tattoos all over
their bodies works really well for some
women um it worked really well for tara
janine had that [ __ ] sick sleeve it's
not for me it's so permanent but tara
was i think motivated by evan at the
time to do all of those tattoos
okay moving on number three
uh jessie jane
jesse jane bless her sweetheart um
jessie jane could be worth a lot of
money
um she's made a lot of money i don't
know how well she's done with it she's
got a party streak in her and when i see
a girl with a party streak i usually
think they're chasing death
um so that's what do you mean by chasing
jeff they're doing drugs they're doing
hardcore drugs
there was a video of her and vegas
passed out on the strip on tnz like two
years ago like she's had her she's had
her rough times and she was one of the
cutest girls another digital playground
contract girl but she's earned enough
money to have money so it's a matter of
did she save it gotcha save that money
as we say
number four on this list
it's tracy lords oh wow tracy lords the
first underage girl to get caught
shooting porn when she was 16 years old
do you remember that
did you mean to be comedic in that
because that was [ __ ] hilarious
she wasn't even born exactly by the way
tracy lords did this when i was a minor
when i was like 14. yeah she said she
this was in the 70s 80s what was that it
was the 80s
mid to late 80s you know i wonder where
she is now
um but she thinks she was the one who
was in trouble she was in trouble but
she got away with it but then it made
her famous
but there wasn't a reality star fame
back then so what could she really do
with it to monetize it right i'm
assuming that she married well and she
these girls at that time were very in
the hollywood scene all the rock and
rollers love them all the and that was
again never my gym i just want to hang
out with my regular friends and make my
money but not fall into that no you've
used those shields you've used that term
married well a few times what does it
mean to marry well it means they married
somebody rich they didn't have to worry
about their own money gotcha so rich is
what you mean by merry well david yeah
not good looking number five i'd say not
good looking
what's more important to you of course
wealth or looks if you can only have one
in a man
um i don't need somebody wealthier than
me but i would like equal or greater
value right i would like to know that
somebody isn't going to take for me to
mind you if they're a teacher or they
work for uh volunteers whatever if you
love what you do but you don't make any
money i'm not judging you for for a guy
um but i think at this age i'll be 50 in
two months um i think well like it's
probably more important than looks
wealth is more important than looks but
yes i think she probably did so you got
a chance david yeah uh number five david
uh number five is brie olson she was
very famous because she was one famous
uh charlie sheens she was one of many
yes she was she was one of charlie
sheen's merry friends he called her a
goddess
i don't really know what bree's up to
right now she pops onto social media
once in a while and we'll we'll chat
um but she lives a bit under the radar
she's one of the girls that could have
secretly saved a [ __ ] ton of money or
she has none
save that money number six is someone
you might be familiar with it is the
lovely luscious lisa anne and the top 10
richest porn stars of all time tell us
about this beautiful lady in this
beautiful scene right here this was the
greatest scene ever which has gone viral
multiple times
david would like to reenact this scene
with you this is not a bad beach it's a
bathtub this isn't a beach it's a
bathtub shark a scare truck so i had to
act like
i had to act like i was a lifeguard and
so they'd run to this location and i was
the fourth scene of the day and they had
already used like the pool the hot tub
everything so the director came to meeks
he knew i had a good comedic sense he's
like okay the only body of water we have
left at this location
is the bathtub do you think you can pull
this off we laughed forever trying to
get this dialogue right but i was like
you know this is what i got to do you
know and it became one of my most
popular scenes
because people loved it they were like
she's gonna and i was and i told him
there was a shark in the bathtub yeah i
had to save him i had the full bay watch
because we were spoofing baywatch
baywatch was baking babe watch right
there yep it was babe david i believe
you've been watching this clip on on
repeat non-stop it's hilarious it's
hilarious it was uh viral on tick tock
the sound people were doing it hey
it's it's what i mean it's one of my
most well known things lifeguard bathtub
that boy right there yeah
who wasn't the brightest lamp in the
store so he did pull that off really
really well he's now a preacher no no
yes so when i promote these this scene
like when i'm doing like a throwback
thursday i always cut him out because i
feel bad like i don't want to shame his
past life if he's a bra if he fought so
hard to get away from it but yes he is a
preacher trajectory for male porn stars
well i mean he uses it right it's like
well this is how i came from i mean
well we all we're all big fans of number
six on this list she's number one to us
let's go let's go on to number seven
david
is katie morgan and believe me she i
think had her own show on hbo i want to
say she sure did she's a baller katie
morgan is hard-working she's a hustler
she's definitely done well for herself
um she owns a lot of her own content and
i would be certain that she is set for
life that's great
david number eight
is jenna hayes i gotta tell you i had a
crush on jenna i'm not gonna lie the now
i know your type
[Laughter]
brown eyes there it is and you know what
she's a very tiny person i don't know if
you know this like she's you know she's
probably like two inches smaller than me
and and totally like a little petite
like a mini person
so she had that so guys liked her
because
her small hands made their dick look
bigger
so like every guy by the way you should
try manscape if that's wrong shout out
landscape shout out to you guys i wanted
to work with her because of her small
hands but
she had a very jenna like the things
that would come out of her mouth she was
disgusting she would say these things
yes like
the [ __ ]
she would say she was just of course
scripted she would no that was her she
was into it explain that something she
was more into some women are like very
vocal and they say the craziest things
they like
the gagging the spitting up like what is
that she was she dated jules jordan for
a long time who has a production company
joel short video and they um and he
shoots a little bit more of that edgier
content that was just like she got in
the business young but she didn't stay
long she stayed won a bunch of awards
stayed maybe three four years um and
since then she's gone back to school she
does a lot of mainstream stuff she's
done well for herself she was good she
is
what a person that makes a ton of money
but will still look at prices things and
i always love that about her because i
can remember being at an event and a
bunch of girls were going back to the
room to order food and they were going
to order like bottles room service and
she's like they were going to wear like
champagne she's like you know we're not
[ __ ] ordering champagne room service
with that extra i'm like i know where
this girl is
talking about that money
we're like we'll just walk across the
street to the liquor store like a normal
person and then we'll use the ice bucket
from the room and then we'll bring our
bottle over let's go
no way socially liberal jenna hayes go
conservatives
uh david number nine number nine
aubry bratoni where'd it happen to that
oh she must have been suspended probably
right yeah yeah she put something racy
up there and ig was like something racy
what have she got cancer slip
skip to the next one yeah well she did
well for herself but she dated some
weird dudes is that what her deal was
yeah yeah okay she's dating an agent
another pretty
and then number 10 we talked about her
earlier she was on entourage she's my
favorite another girl who's not afraid
to say some nasty things is sasha gray i
had a dated gray t-shirt in high school
wow well she dated vinnie chase on
entourage thoughts on her making onto
entourage making money getting into the
mainstream what are your thoughts on
that she's brilliant she travels she
lives in europe a lot of the girls will
move when they want to leave the
industry to other countries because
we're not as
judged uh it's very different um so
that's why a lot of the girls will move
out of america and she travels around
does a lot of cool art stuff like she's
living a great life and i know that life
is because of how well she did with her
money when she was in the business she
also didn't take [ __ ] scenes she also
didn't take [ __ ] money like she knew her
worth from the jump she was a spiegler
girl and spiegler really brings his
girls into the business a different way
why do you think that they chose her to
be on entourage
of all the women out there she had the
right connections look spiegler's other
girl is the girl from euphoria right now
um oh i just watched that episode what
is her name i forgot
yes i worked with her uh in 2019 and her
name chloe chloe chloe
chloe is her first name but spiegler
euphoria clo spiegler has the
contact cherry there she is spiegler has
the contacts with uh
celeb with hollywood mainstream
hollywood and gets his girls in great
stuff so that's how tasha gray got in
that's how chloe got in look at those
lips though yeah uh anyway those are the
top ten apparently uh richest women in
porn how does it feel to be on that list
you know it feels okay i like people not
to think i have really any money because
they don't ask you for any but i mean i
think i think there's probably other
girls that are flying below the radar
that people don't realize when you look
at what everything they do i'll bring up
sheree deville i mean this is a girl
that's working on every single platform
a girl that's always creating content
that owns much most of her content it
could be ever so disturbing to know how
much money she actually makes but
because she's neutral and she doesn't
play the super popular shows need to be
top ten she's never been looked at that
way she's the secret
million millionaire on her way to
billionaire who's not on this list that
you that you would say is absolutely
killing the game right now who are there
a few porn stars that are like cherie
cherry romy rain mm-hmm you know that
name ring a bell with you over there
romy rain romy rain no no okay who else
who's killing the game uh
you would know probably better than why
would i know i think you would know
you're like big